14h10 nous sommes en direct sur brut
pour un entretien exclusif avec le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui durant les prochaines
minutes va répondre à mes questions mais
aussi les vôtres on vous invite dans les
commentaires à poser vos questions dans
un esprit plus constructif possible de
ce live
et puis des questions qu'on a pu
également recueillir vous avez envoyé
depuis hier depuis l'annnonce de ce live
on nous vous à lui et on a remonté donc
certaines questions qu'on va poser donc
au ministre de l'intérieur depuis son
bureau merci d'avoir accepté notre merci
à monsieur castaner nous sommes à la
veille de l'acte 9d gilet jaune
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un
peu du dispositif qui sera mise en place
demain on sait qu'il ya 80 mille membres
des forces de l'ordre qui sont sous le
terme est ce qu'on a des détails à
pouvoir donner à ceux qui nous regardent
d'abord vous dire que des violences en a
tous les jours toutes les nuits en
moyenne ces jours derniers il y avait
entre 1500 et 1700 personnes mobilisées
dans le cadre du mouvement d'idées j des
jeunes mais chaque nuit il ya des
attaques il ya des arbres qu'on abat pas
totalement mais dont on veille à les
abattre suffisant pour qu'ils puissent
tomber dans la journée sur des véhicules
qui peuvent passer des structures
d'alimentation électrique des péages des
radars ça c'est plus classique mais du
coup ces violences sont les a toutes les
nuits plus ont posé la question de
savoir quel sera le dispositif de demain
je vais pas rentrer dans le détail pas
rentrer je vous dis appelé déterminé
qu'il est puissant parce qu'on a vu au
fil de ces dernières semaines que la
violence est toujours au rendez vous de
ces mobilisations dit du samedi et ce
qu'ils ont une sont joints de tactique
sur le terrain on sait qu'on avait vu
une évolution entre le début du
mouvement et ce qu'on a pu voir partir
du 8 décembre avec notamment la présence
de blindés ce qu'on aura des indices
positifs à peu près similaire la grande
différence avec elle vous avez place
istc que on avait une gestion de l'ordre
public qui était assez statique
traditionnellement depuis le préfet
massoni ça remonte à quelques années sur
paris ou en gros qu'il y avait des
manifestations violentes
on essayait de les cantonner
territorialement et puis d'attendre
qu'elle se fatigue comme on dit dans le
sud ou qu'elle s'épuise et ensuite on
intervenait alors qu'en province on
était beaucoup plus opérationnel
beaucoup plus directs savaient que
depuis le début décembre on est sur des
interpellations immédiate chaque fois
qu'il y à des exactions et puis on
essaye d'empêcher
ces exactions ces barricades ces
incendies ces braquages ces cas sage
qu'on a connu et donc le schéma a changé
il changera encore demain mais je ne
vais pas rentrer dans les détails
nous recueillons venir ont pu noter que
vous évoquez mais parlons de bourg on
sait qu'à des appels à manifester demain
dans cette dans cette ville qu'un arrêté
préfectoral seraient pris pour interdire
la manifestation
certains disent que c'est une entrave à
la liberté de manifester qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez madaba n'y a pas de
manifestation demain à bourges ce jour
rappelle qu'en france on est un système
assez simple où ça n'est pas l'état qui
autoriserait manifestation n'en demande
une chose assez simple si je veux
manifester je déclare que je vais
manifester et du coup j'assume un peu ma
responsabilité parce que c'est assez
facile de dire je vais descendre dans un
quartier je vais tout casser on est en
france dans un pays où il ya des droits
il ya des devoirs et notamment celui de
la responsabilité donc il ne s'agit pas
aujourd'hui de changer quoi que ce soit
sur ce régime de base qui est je fais
juste une déclaration de manifestation
et je vais manifester
ce que je regrette c'est que ceux qui
appellent à se mobiliser à bourges n'ont
pas le courage d'assumer leur choix
jusqu'au bout et juste de faire un mail
au préfet de passer un coup de fil à la
sous-préfecture du coin à dire voilà je
veux manifester et c'est ce qui s'est
passé dès le 17 novembre
je peux vous dire que le premier ordre
que j'ai donné dans ce ministère c'est
quand on a vu ces mobilisations le 17
novembre et 2 282 personnes mobilisées
en france dans 1200 points dans des
ronds points c'était le début de la
mobilisation des jeunes sur les
ronds-points le premier ordre que j'ai
donné c'est d'aller protéger les
manifestants parce que nous savions
qu'il y avait des risques et à peine
quelques heures après le début il ya eu
une première personne qui est morte
c'était une manifestante et puis depuis
il ya eu dix personnes qui sont mortes
dans ce cadre voilà et donc assumé de
déclarer la manifestation c'est aussi
permettre aux forces de l'ordre de la
sécuriser pas de l'interdire les eurent
alors été autorisés ou de ce que vous
dites toujours là mais c'est plus simple
que ça si elle est déclarée elle n'a
même pas à être autorisé le droit
français est simple vous déclarez est
automatiquement
vous avez le droit d'aller manifester
voyez on a un système qui est très
protecteur et on se parle de par exemple
amnesty international qu'ils oublieront
mal à une manifestation n'a pas
forcément un buzz
loin d'être déclarée on peut de façon
spontanée pouvoir manifester dont les
rues ont peu de façon spontanée pensais
qu'on peut aller manifester qu'on peut
aller casser qu'on peut caillassé qu'on
peut attaquer les forces de l'ordre
certains peuvent penser que c'est un
droit que c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur c'est le ministère de la
protection de la protection des français
de la protection aussi des bâtiments des
commerces de l'activité économique et
donc il ya quelques règles
elles sont pas très compliqué vraiment
il suffit de déclarer points et donc si
on considère que c'est trop et que c'est
attentatoires aux libertés
je pense qu'on peut débattre de la
notion de liberté je vous parlais de
celle des commerçants qui ont connu ces
dernières semaines des résultats
catastrophiques
je vous parlais des 65 mille personnes
qui sont mis au chômage
en ce moment même dans le cas de chômage
partiel à cause du mouvement chez les
jeunes on peut aussi parler de liberté
de circuler c'est un point fondamental
donc je crois qu'il faut remettre
l'église au milieu du village pour
mettre les choses à leur place
il n'y a pas d' entrave à la liberté de
manifester quand on demande de respecter
un droit assez simple je déclare mais
vous savez c'est pas fait pour déclarer
pour déclarer s'est fait d'abord pour
qu'on puisse organiser de manifestations
et ça s'est toujours fait comme ça sur
un parcours qu'on puisse mettre les
forces de l'ordre de façon proportionnée
juste et ça me paraît nécessaire mais
c'est fait aussi parce que c'est bien
dans notre pays qu'on assume sa
responsabilité
on peut appeler à la révolte on peut
appeler à la casse certains fonds mais
alors qu'ils assument leurs
responsabilités non ils se cachent ils
se cachent derrière l'anonymat ils se
cachent derrière les attaques nocturnes
qu'on a régulièrement sur les
institutions sur la mise en cause des
journalistes de façon systématique mais
toujours dans l'anonymat moi je suis
pour le courage le courage d'assumer sa
responsabilité mais pas pour interdire
quoi que ce soit je ne suis pas un
ministre qui interdit et on à grégory le
clairon et commentaires qui réagit à vos
propos parce que vous faites beaucoup et
ajustement des casseurs des situations
de tension et qui nous dit l'amalgamé
entre la manifestation à la casse et
irresponsables puisque vous me répondez
et en quoi ces responsables vous êtes
journaliste très présents sur la
manifestation
est-ce que vous avez une maître vue vous
comme journaliste une manifestation ces
dernières semaines à paris où il n'y a
pas eu de casse est ce que je fais
l'amalgamme en faisant tous les gilets
jaunes sont des casseurs jamais dès le
début je vais parler de manifestations
et de mobilisation bonnan fond j'ai même
utilisé
mais là il m'a été reproché j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer plusieurs fois
cette semaine systématiquement j'ai fait
la différence entre ce qui porte une
revendication sociale
les revendications institutionnelles et
les casseurs je ne fais pas l'amalgamé
mais je ne dis pas non plus que ce sont
que les ultras qui casse aujourd'hui il
y à des femmes des hommes emportés dans
le mouvement du jeu les jeunes qui
viennent pour la confrontation qui
viennent pour la casse n'est-il pas eu
des erreurs de langage au sein du
gouvernement c'est que certains du
village où l'on était très énervé par
certains propos et notamment ceux du
président de la république parlant de
foule haineuse de personnes radicaliser
pour benjamin griveaux porte parole du
gouvernement est ce que finalement ce
n'est pas des mots qui peuvent mettre de
l'huile sur le feu ouais vous avez
raison on assiste à un mouvement de
bisounours
globalement c'est super sympa en terme
d'ambiance moi chaque fois que je
rencontre les forces de l'ordre au
lendemain du match complet général et
l'allemagne et de canards mais attendez
on peut qualifier des choses il y a des
gens qui ont fait une manifestation bon
enfant et il ya des casseurs il ya des
voyous il ya des assaillants quelles
proportions pour vous entre des gens qui
commettraient des troubles à leur public
et de manifestants pacifiques est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres pouvons nous
donner entre une propension de gens qui
commettraient des actes de casse et des
manifestants pacifiques vous savez il
faut traverser la question ce qu'ils
appellent aux manifestations demain
savent qu'il y aura de la violence et
donc ils ont leur part de responsabilité
que les choses soient claires au début
on pouvait dire oui mais il ya des gens
qui sont venus dans le groupe et qui
vont casser c'est pas nous on porte pas
ça demain je le dis ceux qui viennent
manifester dans des villes où il ya ta
casquette annoncé savent qu'ils seront
complices de ces manifestations la mais
ça naît ça n'a rien à voir avec le débat
politique
vous savez moi je pense que dans ce pays
plutôt que de se battre
on peut débattre il y à une
revendication politique est portée et je
ne la conteste pas je ne parte pas je ne
partage pas tout mais je ne la conteste
pas mais je prône la fin de la violence
et rentrons dans le débat oui dans ce
pays plutôt que de se battre
on peut débattre on a une question qui
se pose beaucoup sur la comptabilisation
des manifestants on sait qu'il ya
beaucoup de critiques envers les médias
aussi envers ministère l'intérieur qui
voient là le ministère de l'intérieur
sous-estiment les chiffres de
manifestants sur le terrain
alors cette question simple comment sont
comptabilisés ces manifestants et qu'est
ce qui garantit que ces chiffres sont
authentiques
le fait de pouvoir faire confiance aux
forces de l'ordre mais comme simples et
soutiendrait je voulais c'est que chaque
préfet en fait au début et d'ailleurs je
vous allez remarquer que j'ai joué la
transparence systématiquement il m'est
même arrivé de corriger les journalistes
pour la manifestation qui a suivi le 31
décembre il ya un chiffre qui est sorti
de 12000 personnes qui manifestaient ce
chiffre ne venait pas du ministère dès
le lundi suivant je dis papa c'est pas
2007 32000 le premier jour de la
manifestation
nous avions donné le chiffre à 17 heures
et puis un peu plus tard j'ai eu
d'autres remontent elles étaient
supérieures le lendemain j'ai dit aux
médias non non attendez c'était pas de
130000 c'était 280000 je suis plus
exactement sur du chiffre mais je les
fait et comment c'est fait dans chaque
département là où il y avait une
mobilisation sur un rond-point à l'heure
où passer les services de police il
zelaya 18 personnes alors tiana 150 un
autre endroit il y en a mille cinq cents
c'est comme ça que l'on cumule les
chiffres et qu'on arrive d'ailleurs à
cette chose qui pourrait paraître
ridicule mais qui correspond à notre
mode de calcul c'est de dire il y avait
trente deux mille quatre cent douze
personnes entre nous il n'ya pas trente
2402 c'était peut-être 500 c'était
peut-être 300 mhz et donc chaque préfet
fait remonter parce qu'on appelle un
préfet de fun le préfet de zone fait
remonter ici à paris dans une cellule
dite de veille qui est tenu par des
policiers par des gendarmes
et ensuite il me donne ce chiffre et ces
chiffres n'ont n'a jamais été trafiqués
truc est tronqué savez ce débat y
compris sur les manifestations de masse
il a eu pendant des années vous savez on
disait les chiffres sont les
organisateurs et les chips souvent la
police et puis certains médias ont pris
en charge un système de comptabilisation
plus technique plus scientifique et où
j'ai remarqué que presque
systématiquement les chiffres selon la
police comme une certaine expérience
sont conformes avec ce nouveau système
moi j'ai jamais dit que ce mouvement
était marginal j'ai jamais cherché à le
sous-estimer quand je dis 280 mille
personnes c'est beaucoup de 180 mille
personnes c'est moins que beaucoup de
manifestations traditionnelles que nous
avons connu par exemple contre la
réforme de la sncf
mais c'est beaucoup mais il ya aussi le
soutien populaire qu'on a connus au
début sur le mouvement
donc je suis pas en train de chercher à
mieux son corps et ses vues
irene qui reste elle cette revendication
sociale cette revendication
institutionnels elle est portée par
beaucoup plus que les 48 ou 49 mille
personnes qui ont manifesté samedi
dernier mais j'assume la transparence
sur ce sujet tout comme j'assume de dire
c'est pas parce qu'un mouvement ne se
réincarner que par tant de personnes
qu'il est juste ou pas juste c'est pas
mon boulot je suis le gardien de l'ordre
public comme ministre de l'intérieur et
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
ce mouvement s'il n'avait pas été
alimentée par la violence dès le premier
jour la violence d'une personne qui
meurt et ensuite la violence de tous ces
accidents qu'on a connu puis la violence
très spectaculaire connu ce mouvement
n'aurai pas la force qu'il a ce
mouvement en fête a été un nid dans
lequel un coucou de violences s'est mis
et donc je ne parle pas des oiseaux qui
était dans ce nid et ce coucou de
violence a fait aussi vivre le mouvement
c'est ça la réalité et je vous dis ceux
qui appellent à manifester ce qui
viennent manifester le savent qu'ils
vont dans des lieux où il y aura des
casseurs parce que maintenant c'est
devenu systématique et que les
informations que j'ai à l'heure où je
vous parle montre que demain oui il y
aura des casseurs qui vont venir pour
casser à paris et partout en france
je n'ai pas d'informations sur partout
en france mais je sais que beaucoup
aujourd'hui s'arme pour venir dans les
manifestations avec la volonté de casser
du côté de la police on peut avoir
parfois certaines voix qui s'élèvent
alors 5 à vichy police qu'il y en a qui
loin d'être majoritaire de mon mieux
mais qu'ils aillent on est en train de
donner une réponse sécuritaire un
problème politique et sociale on entend
même parfois aussi en affrontant deux
journées sont discuter avec certains
policiers qui nous disent on sert de
rempart à l'état qui n'apporte pas
forcément la solution son plan social
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez pas ce
que c'est vrai qu'on en a aussi du côté
des forces de l'ordre des forces de
l'ordre qui font part d'une fatigue
importante qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez vous aujourd'hui c'est que la
réponse sociale c'est répondre à une
question qui est posée
c'était quoi la question qui était posée
le 17 novembre les taxes sur l'essence
et du diesel
la réponse est apportée puis à la
demande sociale et ce qui n'a pas été
apportée trop tard certains y voient là
vous avez laissé ce mouvement ou monter
vous ne m'avez répondu que je ne
l'aimais pas rendre à la question des
impôts
ensuite on a rajouté d'autres mesures
les 100 euros d'augmentation pour les
gens qui sont au niveau du smic par la
prime d'activité ça a fait déborder à
wimille avait-il smic pas celle qu'on
aurait dit ce mec ça n'aurait touché que
1,6 million de personnes
l'activité elle va toucher 5 millions et
puis toute une série de mesures 12
milliards d'euros tous mobilisés tous
confondus c'est quand même pas rien donc
la réponse elle est là et on voit bien
qu à chaque fois qu une réponse est
apportée
ceux qui manifestent nous donnons mais
ça ne suffit pas et des places le sujet
et on a une autre revendication plus
notre revendication plus notre
revendication peut très bien on va en
débattre
on organise un grand débat national et
donc il ya un choix simple soit on veut
débattre
soit on va se battre le choix il est
simple chacun peut choisir moi je
préfère débattre questions sur les
policiers question aussi du côté des
devils ont beaucoup de personnes dans
les commentaires nous font remonter
l'information en rapport avec ce qu'on
appelle les violences policières
présumées il ya eu des signalements
notamment à l'igpn
aujourd'hui certains disent que nous ne
les avaient pas condamner à c est ce que
c'est politique que de la communication
ne pas vouloir en parler à d'abord je
fais de vraies différences entre les
violences contre les forces de l'ordre
et l'ordre quand il se met en avant
j'ai pas tic être policier pour se
défendre c'était j'évoquais le monde des
bisounours tout à l'heure c'était
utiliser des mots ou des invitations à
être responsable mais ce que j'ai vu
systématiquement ce sont des forces de
l'ordre attaque et qui quelquefois ont
dû faire usage de la force pour se
défendre et il ya une vraie différence
il peut que se trouve que la polynésie
match par exemple de ce qui s'est passé
à toulon
vous avez plusieurs images à toulon
tiers est ce que vous avez envie de
diffuser aussi celle où quelques minutes
avant cette image là où effectivement
une personne et interpellé de façon
brutale et j'assume ma responsabilité je
demandé au préfet du département de
saisir l'inspection générale de la
police nationale et donc j'assume ma
responsabilité mais ce que voulait
montrer l'image juste avant quelques
minutes avant quand il est au sol est
tabassé par dix personnes étaient il ya
une vraie différence entre celles et
ceux qui attaquent nos forces de l'ordre
et le fait que nos forces de l'ordre ont
le droit et ce sont les seules forces
ont le droit aussi d'utiliser des moyens
de défense
et vous savez mais ce qu'elle a de force
leur bon si c'est ce qu'il a toujours et
pas je crois en direction des personnes
qui seraient vraiment oise orne et par
ses actions violentes
moi je crois qu'elle l'a toujours été et
systématiquement quand on a un doute
nous saisissons à l'inspection générale
de la police nationale c'est pas un
service de
ministère c'est un service qui a des
fonctions de police judiciaire et qui
fait des enquêtes et là dessus je suis
pour la transparence la plus totale et
j'ai appelé les forces de sécurité avant
les manifestations à ce devoir
d'exemplarité
j'ai présenté mes voeux il ya quelques
jours aux forces de sécurité et j'ai
parlé de ce devoir d'exemplarité et je
leur ai dit que je sais que c'est
difficile parce que quand vous êtes
attaqués et vous avez un quart de
seconde pour réagir là quelques fois
vous pouvoir un geste qui peut paraître
violent et qui du coup mais qui conserve
le trouble mais mais s'il est
disproportionnée s'il ne correspond pas
il est condamnable mais moi ce que j'ai
pu voir aujourd'hui et c'est que nos
forces de l'ordre alors qu'elles étaient
attaqués avec des images extrêmement
violente dont vous avez été témoin et
que vous avez pu relayer ont toujours su
réagir de façon proportionnelle sa une
aux forces de l'ordre à son armée est ce
que une seule fois elles ont utilisé
leurs armes dans les manifestations
n'ont par contre je peux vous dire que
tous les jours toutes les nuits elle les
utilise et c'est justement la différence
entre les voyous qui utilisent la
violence contre nos forces et les forces
de l'ordre qui sont légitimes à utiliser
des moyens de défense
la sécurité elle a besoin aussi de
moyens et c'est pour ça qu'il ya un
ordre dans un pays je vous dire un truc
simple il n'y a pas de liberté
s'il n'y a pas d'ordre parce que s'il
n'y a pas d'ordre c'est toujours le plus
fort qui gagne c'est le plus violent et
je n'aime pas la société de la violence
parmi les armements contester cette
grenade explosive geler les f4 qui
l'accusé d'être responsable de
nombreuses blessures chez les
manifestants elle est composée notamment
de 25 grammes de tnt il ya beaucoup de
manifestants qui sont plaint justement
de blessures parfois grave c'est que
certains ont perdu la main suite à
l'utilisation de cette grenade on sait
qu'il est très peu utilisé leur
entreprise par la suite à l'utilisation
de la grenade
suite au fait qu'ils aient pris cette
grenade dans la main pour la rejeter sur
les forces de l'ordre
il faut à préciser cela cette fameuse
grenade qui effectivement est une wadal
explosive elle n'est que rarement
utilisée elle est utilisée à un moment
donné où les forces de l'ordre ont
besoin de se sortir d'une impasse
ils sont tellement encerclé agressés ils
peuvent l'utiliser et à l'envoi du
lacrymogènes et elle a un effet
assourdissant
c'est une puissance explosive forte
effectivement pour avoir cela elle est
dangereuse
si on la prend dans la main mais moi
j'ai fait cette manifestation est ce
qu'elle sera interdite
mais je vous savez on peut aussi décider
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
justement poule après pas un truc simple
ne prenez pas quoi que ce soit pour le
jeter sur les gendarmes sur les
policiers et c'est simple il n'y aura
pas de blessés pendant des cagnottes qui
a eu voilà la faire avec le boxeur avec
le monte plusieurs fondant sur ce pont à
proximité de l'assemblée nationale
cette cagnotte du côté des forces de
l'ordre finalement qu'est-ce que vous en
retenez avec le recul de ces de ces
initiatives certains indiquent se
séparer encore de consacrer un camp trop
force de l'europe dans notre pro
manifestants
c'est créer un clivage plus important
qu'est ce que voit qu'on a cela jorge
sosa malsain les deux côtés le jeu non
le jeu d'opposer cagnotte record
cagnotte etc
je vois là je trouve ça malsain mais ce
que je trouve dingue c'est que là encore
on trouve normal de cotiser pour
subventionner la violence parce que le
boxeur comme vous dites il a attaqué des
forces de l'ordre il commence à attaquer
en tapant dans le dos d'ailleurs si vous
regardez l'image des taux dessus sur la
passerelle et il tape dans le dos moi je
ne suis pas un sportif et spécialiste en
matière de boxe mais j'ai toujours
appris qu'ils avaient quelques règles
que taper quelqu'un dans le dos était ni
courageux ni fair play en matière de
sport et donc on subventionne la
violence et puis ensuite il ya un
mouvement que je note aussi qu'
allemande soutien à nos forces de
l'ordre et il ya des gens qui décident
de cotiser mais globalement je me serais
bien passé des deux cagnottes je me
serais bien passé de la violence du
boxeur et je sais la situation dans
laquelle il est aujourd'hui vu qu'il est
écroué et donc objectivement ce que l'on
dit de lui c'est que il devrait pas être
en prison
ah oui devrait pas être en prison il de
remettre en prison parce qu'il aurait
pas pu j'aurais pas dû mener cette
attaque extrêmement violente
ce moment où le policier est au sol et
ou à plusieurs et le rouent de coups de
pied c'est ça la réalité aussi certains
parfois par une justice à deux vitesses
un jeu remonte les commentaires qu'on
peut avoir sur ce live encore voilà ce
boxeur comme sfl week-end dernier
il est en détention provisoire
aujourd'hui et d'autres font pareil par
exemple avec alexandre benalla avec tout
ce qu'on lui reproche aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont comme en liberté qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez sa partition qui remonte
beaucoup et qu'on entends me semble mais
je vais antonio s'est d'abord c'est la
justice de l'hommiste d'intérieur il va
ya surtout pas commenter des décisions
de justice mais monsieur benallal j'ai
bien noté quand même que l'opprobre
populaire et compris médiatique a été
donné
l'objet d'une instruction judiciaire est
il dit une chose suivante je suis
intervenu pour protéger les forces de
l'ordre
c'est très différent de celui qui
attaquent les forces de l'ordre il
appartient à la justice de savoir si
c'est vrai ce qu'il dit ou pas moi j'ai
dénoncé très tôt son comportement est
donc je me sens à l'aise sur le sujet je
ne défends pas ni bennani je n'accuse
qui que ce soit mais la réalité c'est ça
dans une manifestation violente où on
voit deux personnes qui jettent des
objets sur les forces de l'ordre je
rappelle que c'était le 1er mai qui
avait aussi beaucoup d action ce jour-là
il intervient il n'aurait pas dû le
faire
il fait l'objet d'une procédure
judiciaire il est une sanction
professionnelle et l'aura peut-être si
les juges décident une sanction pénale
que vous êtes à nouveau convoqués au
sénat monsieur bénard est également vous
avez vous iran bien sûr que je me rende
mais mettons les choses là aussi dans
l'ordre qu'on peut faire de la mise en
scène
ce dont la question qu'on va se poser
d'un à notre faim si on considère qu
effectivement il ya un mail qui a été
envoyé par un sous chef de service un
chaussettes chef de service du ministère
de l'intérieur pour les passeports
diplomatiques c'est pour ça que nous
sommes convoqués avec des questions
techniques
donc si on considère cette affaire
d'état vous avez raison c'est une
affaire d'état
moi je vais répondre ce que me dira le
chef de service qui a changé avec
l'autre chef de service du ministère sur
la question simple de savoir si on a pu
interrompre usage ces passeports ou pas
voilà un vrai sujet qui amende la ville
mobilise tous les français devant des
revendications du mouvement des vies les
gens nous parlent de ce grand débat mon
appareil et quelques milles qui va
commencer dans les prochains jours le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne c'est
aujourd'hui peut-être la revendication
qu'on entend plus sur le terrain quelle
est la position du gouvernement sur ce
sujet moi je suis pas en charge de
grands débats et je ne suis pas le
gouvernement à moi tout seul
ce que je sais c'est que il faut faire
de la démocratie et il faut la faire
vivre le plus possible mais ensuite il
faut aussi avoir quelques garde-fous
parce que je sais qu'il ya des grandes
réformes qui font l'honneur de ce pays
qui ne serait jamais passé si ya eu ce
type de référendum abrogatoire par
exemple j'ai vu que le conseil
économique social et environnemental
avait lancé une grande consultation et
que le premier point dont on demande de
revoir la faisabilité dont on demande
l'abrogation c'est le mariage pour tous
moi je suis un député qui a voté avec
fierté le mariage pour tous et je me
battrai jusqu'au bout pour consoles
mariage pour tous parlons aussi soumis à
une question qui est qui remontait aussi
là dessus sur les interpellations durant
ces manifestations certains accusent le
fait que c'est les interpellations
seraient faites façon préventive et non
sur des faits bien établies ce qu'est ce
que vous leur apprendre à ces chiffres
notamment qu'il parle de 3,5 1339 garde
à vue et 2234 procédure classée sans
suite
peut-être d'autres encore alors on
explique cet écart aussi important entre
le nombre de personnes gardées à vue et
le fait que derrière autant puissent se
retrouver sans charges contre elle alors
juste un détail ces cinq mille trois
cent trente neuf interpellations pas
forcément garde à vue et ensuite il ya
des procédures judiciaires
donc il ya eu seulement 149 personnes
qui ont été mis directement en prison
croyez-le 815 comparution immédiate
et il y en a plus de 1600 qui feront
l'objet d'une convocation ultérieure
mais je vais vous dire une chose simple
non il n'y a pas eu d'interpellations
préventives en france la loi nome assure
aujourd'hui aucune interpellation
présentiez pas nombre paraît assez clair
lorsque c'est vrai que c'est des
remontées à six chiffres qui sont
intéressants de de pouvoir de pouvoir
commenter la mort soit on est dans un
cadre judiciaire
et vous avez des interpellations soit on
est dans la préparation de la
manifestation et on considère que se
promener par exemple avec des boules de
pétanque pour aller manifester sur les
champs elysées ne correspond pas tout à
fait la définition de la pétanque que
j'ai moi qui suis un provençal est donc
à ce moment-là on considère que les
boules de pétanque dont on a signé
d'ailleurs parce que c'est comme ça que
ça se passe avec des produits indélébile
la boule de pétanque seront des armes
par destination parce qu'effectivement
dans quasiment toutes les manifestations
on jette des boules de pétanque sur nos
forces de l'ordre et sur les véhicules
sur des vitrines sur des commerces et
quelquefois sur des clients deux
questions très rapide je les fais deux
ans nul parce que je sais que vous êtes
attendus on pourrait en toute
transparence avec ceux qui nous
regardent une information de de france
entre de france info aujourd'hui qui
parle qui confirment d'autres
informations du journal du dimanche
parlant de la fragilisation du préfet de
police michel delpech pour lequel il y
aurait des critiques énorme envers
justement des dispositifs de police
est-ce que très concrètement il est
menacé aujourd'hui ce cas une réflexion
au sein de votre ministère avec le
président de la république pour son
remplacement je vais faire les
confidences s'il ya un ministère dans
lequel il ya quelquefois de
l'instabilité pour ces chefs
à commencer par le ministre c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur vous savez
c'est peut-être le seul ministère à vous
poser la question de savoir où vous
serez la semaine prochaine et donc quand
vous êtes en responsabilité vous assumer
cela mais il est menacé ou rythme mais
je suis pas là pour commenter telle ou
telle personne c'est un serviteur de
l'état je travaille avec lui au
quotidien today en question le défenseur
des droits de l'homme c'est une
information qui demande aujourd'hui le
défenseur des droits l'homme jette tout
le monde clown enquête pour atteinte à
la liberté de manifester ça revient un
peu sur ce qu ont évoqué au départ mais
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous lui
répondais je répondrai à toutes les
questions qu'ils n'opposent je pense
qu'ils se trompent il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui dans ce pays
d'atteinte à la liberté de manifester je
reprends le début de notre mandat
français pour vous bien son fils raymond
toutes les wii
non franchement oui je viens noter que
certains pensaient que nous n'étions
plus en démocratie dans ce pays dont
klaus attend pas certains parlent même
de à mais certains pensent qu'on est
assis sur leur terrain bien sûr non mais
certains pensent à mais je crois que les
français qui nous écoutent et la peur
aussi de certaines mesures qui ont été
annoncées en début de semaine par
edouard philippe qui pourraient pour eux
contraindre certes vous avez liberté de
manifestation une époque quand on a
interdit à fumer dans les lieux publics
certains pensaient que c'était
attentatoires aux libertés quand on est
obligé à voir la ceinture de sécurité à
l'avant certains ont dit que cet
attentat aux libertés et sur le fichier
quand vous souvenez il y avait des
bagarres dans les stades de foot tous
les samedis tous les samedis extrêmement
violents avec de la haine du racisme de
l'antisémitisme
donc un jour on a dévié dans ce pays de
traiter la question du hooliganisme avec
un fichier effectivement les violons qui
venait pour en découdre pour se battre
pour empêcher les matches n'avaient plus
leur place dans les stades parce que
dans un stade
on fait des matchs de foot ou d'autres
activités et donc là on était sur le
secteur du foot et donc je ne crois pas
qu'on ait menacé le bon déroulement des
championnats de foot
en dix ans les hooligans qui viennent
pour casser n'ont plus leur place dans
les stades mais je vous le dis les
casseurs qui viennent pour casser qui
viennent pour frapper qui viennent pour
lyncher nos forces de sécurité n'ont pas
leur place dans les manifestations
et ils n'ont pas leur place par
il est chez les jeunes merci monsieur
kassai remise de l'inter donc qu'ils ont
c'est donc dans son bureau aujourd'hui
on aurait encore eu plein de questions
mais ça que vous êtes vous êtes attendus
en toute transparence pour ceux qui nous
regardent ont laissé en tout cas de
remontée
les tendances de soleil les questions
que vous avez pu nous écrire également
pour pouvoir les transmettre à bien en
guise de l'intérieur qui vient nous nous
répond cela est-ce que vous pourrez voir
ou revoir dans quelques instants en
replay comme toutes nos vidéos en direct
vous pouvez vous retrouver en
intégralité à disponible sur la page
facebook de brut merci encore à vous
merci de l'intérieur et bonne journée à
tous ceux qui nous regardent et on se
retrouve très très vite pour de
nouvelles images en direct